ant-man himself plays Scott Lang an
ant-man in ant-man and the wasp in
theaters near you July 6th good to see
you Paul Rudd it's great to see you and
your your your your normal-sized self
I'm describing for the radio audience
now you're right gigantic and your smile
seemed you know I can't if I showed up
really small
it's pointless you couldn't be able to
see me yeah be too big I don't fit in
the chair so you just showed up just as
yourself yeah that's your being a team
player you want to promote this film you
want to get it out there in the proper
way I hear you Paul you know it's it's
it's it's it's about you rich thank you
thank you I got my name come on a mug I
got you on a mug you have this mug at
home I told you I told you that I drink
out of you a couple times a week I'm
honored
I'm so honored in that respect how do
you feel about I know that you've just
it's so identifiable now this in your
kind of your symbol your insignia of
running the 40 how do you feel about
like that that do you like it the fact
that what that I that people because
they're just so you know that's I just
see it everywhere now you just your
buddy Jon Hamm yeah um who's been at a
big slick many times and who you go way
back with he was here a few weeks ago he
called it a very Don Draper looking
thing he thought that he I see it he
started mimicking like I was falling out
of a building with the mug cigarette in
your hand with that effect your 40 time
being three fingers deep into a stiff
drink is definitely gonna affect my 40
times huh yeah yeah no I see the Mad Men
heat imagery sure and last we saw you
Kansas City we saw you at the big slick
congratulations on a two million bucks
yeah unbelievable
Children's thank you for coming and
thank you for doing the show from there
it was amazing it was a lot of fun it's
you've been you've been before and I
really appreciate it that Hospital is a
pretty amazing place and the work they
do there is great and this year we broke
all kinds of records over $2,000,000
million bucks and part of that too is
when you you we were blown away by it
too on the stage the the night of the
big fundraiser down comes out of the
rafter
the Captain America shield shield signed
by all of the Avengers and you went
around yourself on the set of yeah of
all of the above
yeah and just what's been on sand
everybody walked around we were all
there at the same time yeah
like hey right ah do you mind can you
sign this for the kids and they also
everyone said yeah everyone did how many
names did you get on that thing uh about
thirty would you say I think there's
more I think there's more I mean I mean
there's you know there's all kinds of
people in there I think everybody that's
worked on a Marvel film is that made out
of real metal was that that's made out
of real vibranium it's usable real
vibrant real vibranium which I gotta be
honest is not easy to get through
customs yeah but your your ant-man
so yeah i can you know i found a way or
you did find a way a paul rudd here on
the Rich Eisen show and that was just a
great like I said just a great weekend
and we were for having a lot of fun in
Kansas City and in Kauffman Stadium yeah
the day that you were out there and you
came by you were at Saberhagen that was
the coolest thing doing the show with
Bret Saberhagen and I had found my
baseball hat actually was my dad's from
the 1985 World Series or I think I maybe
gave it to him or I don't remember we
had the same one and I and so when I
find I found that hat and then I was a
week later doing the show with Bret
Saberhagen got him to sign it I know and
then the fact that where did we were
hanging with him he was just like the
coolest guy yeah he's been to a couple
of big slicks on or two he's awesome and
George Brett was gonna be there but I
heard he was at the hockey game like he
was at the Washington Capitals game or
something like that which was well that
was very excited you can't blame him for
that I mean the Washington Capitals I
was you know I just didn't know the
Royals capitals connection in that
regard yeah yeah huge there's it's big
it's big you know the drought that the
Capitals had from where they did never
won before it was even a longer dress it
was similar to a similar deer I have a
buddy a friend and his son
they are such diehard capitols fans
arrived out here and he
couldn't even speak when they won he was
out of his mind now when you are sitting
next to say Reagan we kind of touched on
it here now let's run that where they're
sitting here in Los Angeles a few weeks
removed I mean the little kid in you is
like flipping out right despite
everything that you've gone through in
your life your career it's yeah you know
Sports has a way of doing that to it
it's you never lose I don't think like
the the fan worship kind of thing right
when I see any of those players if I see
any of the Chiefs if I see any kind of
professional football player that I even
you know admired as a kid or the for
another team I'm like whoa I can't
believe it I you know when I was a kid I
loved the Steelers and I one time I was
able to get into the locker room with a
guy who knew Bradshaw
I saw Lynn Swann over by the locker room
how old were you I was about 10 mm-hmm
and and my the guy that was friends a
brash I worked with my dad he goes you
want to go say hey to Lynn Swann and I
was like I'm good I'm okay I so badly
wanted to do it but I was so nervous
mm-hmm that I just couldn't bring myself
to doing it and and then most of my life
even as an adult I was like why didn't I
say hi to Lynn Swann I would have really
that would have been really really cool
would you like us to take care of that
at some point I'll tell you that would
be pretty now we be pretty cool if you
could swing with John Stallworth that
dudes my all-time favorite Tim
Stallworth when I was a kid always
stallworth where did the Steelers love
come from just I think that you know
there was it when when you were at that
time you were either Cowboys or Steelers
it seemed like it seemed like two teams
existed mm-hmm but I used to before I
moved to Kansas City when I was a kid I
we had a football pencil machined at our
school and I used to give the Steeler
pencils to this guy that worked with my
dad that was from Pittsburgh and so the
Steelers were playing I was living in
California they were playing the LA Rams
and he took me I was in first grade and
that changed my life I was a such a
Steelers fanatic as a kid to this day
I need to remember a number and a phone
number and address or something right
I'll associate it with a player from
like the 70s late 70s Steelers if you
name a number I'll see if I don't even
know go for it Chris but son this is all
this is the plan we haven't planned this
okay this is this all jog to go through
the go to the Pro Football Reference
and and we'll put together a phone
number for Paul Rudd area code first
we'll figure it out for his Steelers
wait you're in particular I don't know
me go like 79 1979 Steelers call him up
I don't know this is fantastic I have no
idea 78 79 what you know I don't think
you got it over there Chris yep okay for
Paul Rudd let's let's do Rocky Bleier
he's 2020 correct mm-hmm
wen Suan 88 Benny Cunningham 89 Larry
Brown 79 nailing it or do this feel Bell
Bell 83 83 if you want come on say a
number and I'll see if I can get that
player nice 6363 was that earning homes
tom oh it Tom Dorn Brooke yeah yeah oh
right right right right right
Ernie Holmes was he was before 79 okay
give another one 47 47 was Mel Blount
correct 59 59 was Jack Hamm 52 52 Mike
Webster they're all correct fantastic
very impressive
58 for the win 58 for the win would be
Jack Lambert from Kent State University
guys Paul Rudd pinched a Pittsburgh
Steeler numerologist Paul Rudd I had no
idea about that yeah with your memory
like that with the Steelers so when this
started well I mean recently as you know
the Steelers King this Chiefs can't get
past the Steelers do you still have a
little bit of Steel a little like I
still like the Steelers I always have
they've just but what happened I think
is that when I was a kid you know after
all my favorite players kind of
left the team and then I was in the kind
of gray area for a few years oh and uh
you know what I really like the Chiefs
and I was a kid still I was still a kid
and then I left I moved away from Kansas
City and then I was like oh man I'm
Chiefs all the way and now it's
absolutely and has been for decades the
Chiefs are the you know I find that a
lot of people when they move away from
their hometown mm-hmm that's when they
get really into their their teens sure
so I mean with stone Street when you
were with honor on our show it bakes
like where you were there with
Saberhagen Stone Street bought brought
Mitchell Schwartz with him mm-hm
our favorite moment that was at the end
of that interview where I said to
Mitchell Schwartz you know hey thanks
for coming by it's great having a member
of the tribe here and Stonestreet goes
Chiefs we're like no wrong Trotman
different tracks you know yeah and
Schwartz is member of you know yeah
that's right right that's it we take
great pride we take great pride in our
professional Jewish athletes because
we're a few and far between I know
that's in a pamphlet not a book from
airplane I'd like something light to
read we have this leaflet of great
Jewish sports heroes we'll take a break
when we come back we'll talk ant-man on
the loss with Paul Rudd and also I know
you are a fantasy player yeah aficionado
fantasy aficionado yeah we have a bunch
of fantasy team names that we've just
been thrown out there because it's been
a part of our our back and forth for
damn they're a full year we've been
stockpiling names we'd like to throw
them in your direction and have you
choose one for us to use this fall I
love this fantastic we're back with Paul
Rudd in 60 seconds
all right back with Paul Rudd ant-man
and the wasp in theaters near you on
July 6th we had Laurence Fishburne on
Monday show who is that guy but most
interesting man in the world yeah yeah
really interesting story really
fascinating person really nice guy not
many people I see the four at least
first first one I've ever met where he
starts telling his story well you know I
think we we went [ __ ] fighting off the
set of Apocalypse Now when I was 14
years old like I've never heard anybody
started a sentence that
I don't think I think there might be
only one person on the planet that can
start a sentence that way and that's him
and that's him and then you're in this
film with Michael Douglas as well
second time that you're with him what is
it like being around another member of
royalty yes it's incredible
I mean thankfully I mean he's so awesome
such a cool just chill really chill yeah
very funny we've gotten to the point now
where we're we you know we talk about
our families and world events and sports
and stuff like dad he says big sports
fan and so yeah it's it was fun we'll
talk like wouldn't the Royals are doing
well and he's saying you know how you
feeling about the season same with the
Chiefs he likes the Jets
but Michael Douglas is a Jets he's a
Jets fan and and so yeah so but we we
yeah he's getting to know him and hang
out in like a regular person right it's
still kind of overwhelming you just
think because he's such a great actor
and as as great of an actor as he is
he's just as great a human being well
it's interesting that you say you talk
about families and stuff with him
because this is a family film ant-man
and the wasp correct like this is star
this is I think that all ages can enjoy
this film I think some kids that want to
see some Marvel films that this one is
not a bad one to take him to very well
it's funny and it's not quite so scary
visually it's really really imaginative
and kind of mind-blowing
and it's also good because you don't
want kids to be scared of bugs and if
you've taken this all of a sudden I
think they'll have a different
relationship with ants and wasps okay
there you go
you know so if you're looking to get
your child in a better relationship
that's right that's right let's mix that
phobia at a young age right just get it
right out bud that's right okay and
that's in theaters near you on on July
6th how are your how's your baseball
fantasy team going there right now yeah
they're not too bad they're actually
doing when you say they're you have
multiple they're that well they're not
too bad because I'm just assuming there
are a bunch LT you only have one team
but I'm saying there is a collection of
players my team my team's not doing
so so bad actually who's on your fantasy
baseball team well I had a really
amazing thing where I am first round I
had the second pick and the guy didn't
take Mike Trout so I did and then on the
second round
Bryce Harper fell to me in the second
round how many teams right there's a
it's a smile that's a heading 12 12 guys
so you're saying with pick 23 yeah I
don't know I think everyone's like oh my
god he's out there and everyone was so
Bryce Harper everybody just assumed he's
been taken slapped on him say you Paul
Rudd in the second round Harper yeah but
he's been slumping a little bit of late
yeah but you know what he's still he's
still pretty awesome right when it's a
long season right yeah all right so who
are your pitchers who's the rest who do
you have as your I'm your fan yeah well
finally has just come off the DL for me
is Bumgarner have him on my okay now
he's starting but Clevenger mm-hmm
god I made the mistake of drafting Snell
and dropped him early on okay I'm
blanket I've Greinke okay some some of
my guys have not been I Oh Donny I took
in the draft
I drafted him I know I have a lot of
guys on the DL I drafted pretty well
sounds like you've drafted yeah
excellent I got I got I drafted a Cunha
a Cunha mm-hmm he's on the DL matata
hakuna matata that's a great name for a
fast the only time I ever mixed a player
in my fantasy name was when I had when
my team name was cuckoo for Coco Crisp
and the avatar was the was the the
player or the cereal
I don't remember hmm I think it might
have been the I think it might have been
the bird so what is your current fantasy
team name your baseball fantasy team
name currently it's heavens to
Murgatroid so just do you want pizza
Barbera I went hanna-barbera I don't
know I don't know why I really couldn't
at the last minute I couldn't really I
couldn't really think of one I thought
of one at
to the fact because I I passed a sign I
was driving down a rural road and saw a
sign advertising a men's breakfast
that's a that's a good name Anna C team
an immense breakfast and the avatar
would be actual breakfast and pancakes
okay I'm thinking there's the first
thing that pops my fig cuz you know
we've had this conversation before about
your fantasy team names my favorite one
that you've had was Dench exclamation
point yeah just for Judi Dench yeah Judi
Dench game faces my hit was the logo
that's inch what's the name of your
current football one which one did you
just go with your football then this
last one was tears of elegance and it
was a single rose I'm thinking next year
I'm thinking next year in keeping with
the exclamation point yes of just going
with snacks because because so many
times I write thanks to quickly it
doesn't get spelled shut no and so
that's gonna be my tonight snacks
exclamation point I'm the avatar is just
a phone or a text bubble or something
like that I don't know I haven't really
you know we're trying to I don't I don't
I don't really know a lot of times a lot
of times for no reason whatsoever the
logos of my teams are just really happy
children okay I had one I had one team
name that was just called sounds and
smells and it was and then my logo was
just some laughing child nothing so you
are the perfect person for this Paul
sounds and smells you're the perfect
person for this because on occasion acts
well we are having a conversation here
on the show I will say something out
loud and and just say to Chris write
that down it sounds like a great fantasy
team yeah we have compiled eight of them
great we have made a bracket and you
will choose which one advances in sort
of n-c-double-a tournament style all
right okay all right you go the Rich
Eisen show fantasy football team name
for this fall of 2018 is about to be
decided by Paul Rudd
do we have music for this Michel tifo
very good alright Chris what's the the
first bracket for alright alright first
match up Paul is Dolan wormhole against
great big boban ass okay so Dolan
wormhole is what I go down every time I
[ __ ] about James Dolan of the Knicks I
can't get out of it yeah and then boba
is you know the seven foot five center
of the Clippers when Susie and I were
sitting courtside we could not see when
he was checking in the game because we
saw a great big bull by an ass in front
of us right which one do you think is a
better fantasy team man that would be
advanced and you put it back up again I
think I think I like the wormhole one
more only because I'm not a fan of
profanity and then in the name ok Dolan
wormhole adults
okay Chris I think like you could mix
the ass and just go with great big boban
oh that's pretty good
that's workshopping it but that's Dolan
where am i those two I go I say don't
Chris Rock okay alright don't warm home
moves on next up Hockley watermark mm-hm
against premature Horning oh you never
want to go premature a warning obviously
Notre Dame great the trophy winner Paul
Hornung yeah what do you think and and
of course at hockey of course I I think
I like the cryptic nature of premature
warning so oculus oculi watermark which
was we created a fake retirement letter
for Ed Hochuli when he announced his
retirement and people actually bought it
it went viral out premature warning is
in I think we have our first upset so
with premature warning against look I
love Ed Hochuli
let's go to the other side of the
bracket okay we have an ignorant piss
merchants against deep logging deep
logins cuz Kenny we noticed how did the
Caddyshack song and Top Gun yeah decided
to go deep logins on that oh well he's
not only that get Caddyshack too
that's what caused us to go deep yes
it's deep logging and that song was you
remember the song what was that again
nobody's fool what nobody's fool
nobody's fool
and nobody's fool don't you so deep
logins analyze deep logins okay the last
one and the last the last matchup here
we have touch of the Vermeil against
Thor's power Jim well as a Chiefs fan
does this one isn't even a question a
touch of the resistive touch of the
Vermeil that's when you choked up about
something you get a touch of the Vermeil
yeah or or if you're if you're ordering
a specialty wine yes and touch of the
Vermeil okay down to the final four no
okay okay the final four we have Dolan
wormhole verse against premature Horning
and deep Loggins vs. touch of the Verma
who advances match one to the fun so
I've got to choose between Zola and
wormhole and premature Horning all right
I'm gonna I would say premature Horning
advances there against oh that's a tough
draw this is Sophie's Choice between
deep logins and touch of the Vermeil you
know this is one where I've just got to
just I just got to go a hometown on this
one because I'm a bigger fan of Dick
Vermeil than I am of Kenny Loggins in
touch of the Vermeil is going to do it
to just touch of the Vermeil and that's
the is that you I'm sorry because deep
Loggins is a great name you can use that
for a year yeah years I would even use
no I'm not gonna use that it's that's
taken that's like you know it's like
putting on your stepdads clothes I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna a
rash it's a sick it's like the stepdad
putting on the original dad's clothes
I'm gonna I'm gonna say I mean look if
it was a if it was a if it was between
Deeb Loggins
oh I never mind I can't even forget it
so it's Paul Hornung versus touch of the
Vermeil what really I think you should
be between deep I think it gets down to
between between deep lugs it's a problem
with the seedings no I don't I don't I
don't so now do I have to choose between
premature the TV deer fantasy team is
gonna be touch of the vermin and in
avatars gotta be him choked up right yes
of course a cry touch of the Vermeil
yeah or a bottle of his wine so how
about this why don't you take deep
logins for your fantasy team this fall I
don't want to do it okay I got too many
things I'm thinking ketoacidosis I got a
bunch I'm making a list of my own do you
remember the first one and when we
played years ago rich remember the first
not forget which one wasn't it first
started it was a taste like chicken
that's taste like chicken I do remember
that I'm the NFL Network celebrity
that's right fantasy if first year
that's right tastes like chicken to
touch of the Vermeil we've seen it all
yeah you know you know I like the story
behind Hayes I chicken is a very funny
one it is but I don't know if it's
really appropriate for this for the for
the show so that's it's you're working
blue would taste like chicken
it just when I went what maybe think we
really made me laugh and I'll tell you
after I'm sorry
it's terrible to do tease up like that
and then not say what it's all right
well you'll tell me and then I'll pass
it along okay man and the wasp in
theaters near you on July the 6th look
forward to seeing that brother thanks
for stopping by
thank you once again for having the oh
thanks for letting me pick your team
name I hope no you nailed I'm sorry
fellow I'm sorry I apologize profusely
to Kenny Loggins yes you should know
great sis throwing us to break right
ant-man of the wasp oh yeah July 6th
nice from another sequel right exactly
yes very good
power-chord there it is touch of the
Vermeil baby the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience